it is an unsettling sight an astonishing
scene in a place that knows the perils
of war
u.s troops with guns and gear on the
ground in eastern
poland three thousand troops will make
camp here in a community called yashanka
although the soldiers have given it a
new name
[Applause]
it's j-town now with the local arena
serving as their barracks
this deployment is symbolic it's a
signal of strength as the russian
military threatens ukraine
but it's difficult to know what vladimir
putin will do as nato builds up its
forces
this sleepy regional airport has begun
to resemble a sophisticated military
encampment and that constitutes a clear
rejection of one of moscow's key demands
that nato pull its forces out of eastern
europe
and it could exacerbate tensions with
the russians even further
for the polls this is proof of a new age
of conflict a contest that will require
europe to re-on
but there is gratitude here for nato
support
actually i think it's the first time in
history that anglo-saxon troops have
come to poland potentially to defend us
against the foreign aggressor so big day
it's a clear signal to mr putin and his
generals that this is where nato
territory starts and it will be defended
and on a quick visit to the capital the
u.s defense secretary restated his
support announcing the sale of tanks and
planes to the poles
you know it's ironic that what mr putin
did not want to see happen was a
stronger nato
on his flank
and that's exactly what he will see
going forward
two million ukrainians have made poland
their home working or studying at
universities
but these students in jesus are finding
it difficult to concentrate
i have family there
i also have a father in the military i
am trying to filter the information
so i'm trying not to panic like as most
people do and there is a question every
ukrainian in poland asks what do they do
if russia invades
personally i would
take my mom from ukraine
i i know that there are actually
movements that say that they want to
stay to stay in ukraine
whenever
whatever would happen
but i will take my mom
for sure to poland
but this was upsetting for yurina she
feels they have a duty to return is it
uh
okay i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i didn't
plan to be honest like my first thought
when i realized that something like this
can be happened it's what it was like i
will go back home like uh i don't know
why like people are escaping i want to
go back i don't know uh why
like i know why because i love my
country
but
the invasion of ukraine seems
unthinkable to some
but the polls have begun to prepare
refugees will be welcomed and the
military stands ready to defend
john sparks sky news in jesus